[Music]
I think we tend to remember
extraordinary acts of kindness simply
because they are extraordinary the act
is a reminder to us of our common
decency our desire to help other people
to care for other people which I think
we all have as kids but as we grow older
we just kind of tend to forget there was
this one experience that I'll never
forget as a few years back and my wife
and I were in Japan
[Music]
so my wife and I decided to visit this
lovely little village in the countryside
that we'd read about and we lose track
of time realized too late that we've
missed the bus and because we're out in
the middle of nowhere there's not
another bus in time to take us to the
airport in two-hour flight
we tried to take a taxi but Tokyo was
simply too far and nobody is willing to
take us we're becoming increasingly
desperate and then just at that moment
sort of mock our desperation the heavens
opened up and it started to rain so it
was really at our lowest point when this
elderly gentleman came up to us we tried
to explain to him as best we could that
we needed to get to Haneda Airport and
we need to get there pretty quickly we
don't know if he understands a word
we're saying but ultimately he just kind
of gestures for us to follow him at this
point were you know increasingly
desperate so I figured why not whatever
you got to lose
so before long we find ourselves back at
we presumed to be his house we have no
idea what's going on at this point were
completely confused but then we go to
his driveway and what do we see in his
driveway it's a taxi the guy's a taxi
driver he offers to drive us to Haneda
great
problem solved incredible we load up our
luggage and it takes us on this
incredible drive through the countryside
through the mountains through the city
and it was like we were having our own
kind of private tour of Japan it was
amazing honestly we were a little
disappointed when I was over we get to
the airport and the most amazing thing
happens I asked him how much the fare is
and he says no no you there's no fare
I said well please you know let me at
least pay for the petrol you know you
just driven us all this way
[Applause]
he just smiles and he he waves and he
wishes us our best and he gets in his
car and he's gone it was then I realized
I didn't even know his name
[Music]
so we board the plane everything's fine
and it was all because this this random
man had seen that we needed help and it
helped us and you know that's something
that I will always remember and so you
know to our random Japanese Savior I
just want to say thank you and to say
that I will try to live by your example
try to do kindness as often as I can try
to teach my kids Grace and goodness and
kindness and charity thank you for the
reminder and thank you for that
[Music]
you